so the Domino's situation mr. Patrick
Doyle's the president is putting up a
video responding to the big ups thing
that's going on out there that uh that
you know to employees did something
dirty now first of all real quick I
think Patrick does a great job by
addressing it head on right away
brilliant move one thing I would say is
you know reading off a teleprompter does
not make it genuine mr. Doyle I'm sure
you could have just done that from the
heart
don't let your PR team give you all the
proper words all you needed to really
say was what you said which is come on
if we're really gonna think that two
people in the world can affect your
brand that globally I know there's a lot
of press around it but if anybody is
naive enough to think that this is only
a dominoes issue and that this can't be
done at McDonald's or KFC or anywhere in
the world they're being extremely naive
and I think it's great that you uh
addressed it head-on but what I want to
talk about is the aftermath of this I
was just gonna call two seconds ago
that's what led me to jump on this flip
cam and I was talking to a brand as many
of you know AJ and I are launching a
company called vaynermedia so we're
we're consulting for a lot of consumer
and personal brands things are going
fairly well got a lot of good projects
going and some big deals already but
most of all this brand is now scared
they don't want to uh they don't want to
do it they're like look at what happened
at Domino's I think that's great I mean
it's it sucks to lose a consulting
opportunity but it's great that a lot of
people are not going to get involved in
social media because of this because
that just lets the people that are smart
and get it have a bigger opportunity for
market share if you're a brand you're
scared off by this you completely have
no clue of where the world is today
this is opportunity to communicate
Domino's situations actually the reason
social media is awesome or quote-unquote
social media I just call it business the
fact that Domino's has the same outlet
to go out and apologize and address the
issue right away and be authentic they
win they were very authentic except for
the reading of the teleprompter Joe
don't look over here look directly into
the camera you know what you want to say
Patrick um so here's what I think I
think it's great that people are not
going to get involved in this space
because they're scared
because it leaves more for all of us
that get it I also think it's great for
the people that understand what Domino's
did was exactly right addressing it head
on
unlike Amazon for the Amazon fail where
they waited two or three days after a
mistake to address it and I also think
it's absolutely phenomenal that people
think this is the downside of branding
and social media you have no choice this
is gonna happen anyway you can't close
your eyes you know this is the downsides
of social media this is not the downside
this is the reality everybody has a
voice but more importantly the truth
wins unhappy those two employees are in
trouble um I don't want them to have a
felony I think people taking it too
extreme and people wanna burn them but I
think it's great that because of all
these tools and technologies so much can
go on as a matter of fact Domino's
McDonald's Pizza Hut you want a good
idea why don't you start you screaming
live from your back of your room so we
can all watch I'd love to watch on my
iPhone on a live streaming app like a
kite or something like that of the back
room and watch them make my burger you
want to be transparent and authentic do
that I mean the games changing guys the
game is changing you cannot control your
message it's owned by the people the way
you respond and address things is the
whole game